joining me now is mike davis president
of the article 3 project and former
clerk to supreme court justice neil
gorsuch you know mike does this mean the
request for a special master doesn't
really matter anymore
not at all so the biden justice
department and the fbi has a pretty bad
track record
as it relates to president trump we've
seen that they have weaponized they have
politicized law enforcement repeatedly
to get trump this is
this was an unprecedented unnecessary
unlawful home raid on a former president
the whole legal basis
for the raid has been blown apart they
they went after trump they said he may
have violated the espionage act that's
not even possible as the
commander-in-chief he can declassify
anything he wants they say he may have
stole or
misused government property under the
presidential records act and other
statutes that's just not possible
there's a 2012 a decision by an obama
judge that that former presidents can
take personal records with them when
they leave office so there goes the uh
the obstruction allegations it's legally
impossible to obstruct non-crimes like
they're trying to uh investigate here
there's a there's a track record of
lying in this case they leaked out that
attorney general merrick garland did not
personally approve this raid that's a
lie they leaked out that trump had
nuclear documents at mar-a-lago that's a
lie they leaked out that president biden
in the biden white house was not uh did
not have a heads up about this raid
that's a lie president biden had to
waive president trump's executive
privilege in order to pave the way for
this raid i think judge cannon
understands that they also they also yet
attorney general merrick garland said he
deliberated four weeks to make this
decision well okay so trump had these
documents for 18 months the attorney
general had to deliberate for weeks and
they weighed it three days after they
got a warrant from this biased
magistrate judge bruce reinhardt who
just recused in trump's civil lawsuit uh
eight weeks ago somehow his bias went
away if trump had such damning records
down there why did they wait so long why
did they wait to go get these documents
that's a really good point but you know
mike here's what a cnn counterterrorism
analyst said about the dni leading a
damage assessment on the trump documents
watch
this is a curious one because typically
if you're going to do a damage
assessment you know that something bad
has already happened i don't mean so
many storing
documents improperly i mean for example
a spy giving away documents to the
russians
mike what do you think about the phrase
damage assessment being used here
they are covering their tracks here
because they know that president trump
declassified and took his personal copy
of the crossfire hurricane records
russian collusion records and those are
damning for
the biden obama hillary
clapper susan rice the fbi the intel
community and that's what that's what
has terrified them and that's what has
precipitated this home rate and it it's
unprecedented it was unnecessary and
unlawful and that's why they did this
and this is a cleanup job so mike so
what are the next steps now for team
trump where do they go from here
so they've they've won this preliminary
motion or it looks like that judge
cannon's going to rule in their favor i
think trump needs to file an amended
rule 41g motion under the federal rules
of criminal procedure to get back all of
these this property all these records
that was seized by the the biden justice
department and he can tee up these legal
issues right now with judge cannon in
the southern district of florida get
this resolved by judge cannon and the
11th circuit court of appeals instead of
you know some trump deranged democrat
judge in the d.c district court and the
d.c court of appeals i think that
president trump and his legal team need
to go on offense mike well said thanks
for joining me tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else